[Musique]
il ne s'agit pas seulement de croire en la paix J'ai
mes propres valeurs et mes valeurs sont que
ce n'est pas la bonne chose à faire pour
contrôler les autres ce n'est pas ma
croyance Je crois en la démocratie Je crois
que moi  et mon voisin devrait avoir les
mêmes droits et si je veux
réaliser mes valeurs et respecter mes valeurs, nous
devons opter pour la solution à deux États
[musique] dont
nous avons besoin pour affronter la réalité. Cette
attaque vicieuse a poussé même les gens qui croient en la
paix et  j'aimerais voir des
relations pacifiques avec les Palestiniens, pleines de
colère, de méfiance à l'égard des Palestiniens,
à côté de cela, il y a autre chose qui
se passe et c'est l'opportunité
dans
cette guerre pendant toutes les années où nous savions
que le Hamas n'était pas un partenaire, un partenaire
pour la paix mais il y a une alternative
pour le Hamas et pour détruire
Kamas, ce n'est pas seulement par l'armée, c'est
aussi par l'idée et le soutien public du
Hamas et la seule façon de combattre le Hamas à
ce niveau est de montrer que l'
Autorité palestinienne  ce ne sont pas les Kamas
qui condamnent le Hamas, ce sont des partenaires d'
Israël et parce qu'ils sont
nos partenaires, ils ont beaucoup de choses à gagner
de la négociation avec
[Musique]
Israël,
de mon point de vue, la sécurité a
toujours été au-dessus de la paix, nous ne pouvons pas
dire cela  nous ne parlerons pas ou ne penserons pas ou
ne souhaiterons pas la paix cela dépend de la
paix avec qui nous ne pouvons pas faire la paix
avec je ne sais
quoi Les barbares sauvages qui tuent leurs
enfants [Musique]
finissent-les tous comme des meurtriers du Hamas si nous
veulent la paix et si les États autour de nous
veulent la paix, nous devons les détruire
exactement comme le monde a détruit Al-Qaida
avec Isis et tous ces fous
qui essaient
de tuer tous ceux qui ne
pensent pas comme
eux,
le succès majeur  des extrémistes en
Israël et en Palestine
déconnectent les sociétés israélienne et
palestinienne les unes des autres,
alors ils jouent sur cette peur que la
paix est impossible, nous ne pouvons pas faire confiance à
l'autre côté, non, il y a beaucoup de
gens dans les deux  les côtés auxquels on peut faire
confiance [Musique] cela devrait être un signal d'alarme très fort
pour chacun un autre cycle de
guerre un autre cycle de violence cela
n'apportera aucune stabilité à cette région
le seul moyen durable d'instaurer la paix
au Moyen-Orient  est de rassembler
les gens pour leur faire
comprendre que la guerre n'est pas la voie à
suivre et n'apportera aucun résultat personne ne
gagne dans la guerre la guerre est facile à faire
la paix est plus difficile à faire, surtout quand
vous avez deux communautés qui étaient si
différentes  profondément blessé à la fois mentalement et
physiquement, mais nous devons encore une fois
rassembler les gens pour construire cette confiance afin que
vous sachiez un avenir probablement brillant pour
nos euh pour nos
enfants [musiciens] la politique israélienne et la
politique de la communauté internationale doivent être il n'y a
aucun moyen  laisser perdurer
ce genre d'
idée fausse selon laquelle ces groupes terroristes
peuvent tirer des missiles sur une base hebdomadaire et
mensuelle sur des civils, cela
doit être stratégiquement changé parce que
ce que vous voyez ici en Israël en 2023,
vous le verrez en France en
2033 et c'est ce qui s'est passé.  être et un
consensus
Consensus international sur cet aspect politique
démilitariser Gaza démilitariser le
Liban et ce n'est pas le
problème israélien c'est le problème international ou celui du
monde libre
[Musique]